Speaker 1: So many of you wrote to me and said,
David, you've got to check out this new interview
that Jordan Peterson did with Joe Rogan. I don't
know how many of you have been following, but
Jordan Peterson after. I mean, I don't even know
that I feel the need to completely characterize
it. But he basically due to medical, you know, we
could call the medical issues addiction issues. He
dropped off the public face of the Earth for years
and then now he's back. And it might not shock you
guys that in the context of the COVID pandemic,
he's sort of on this man. It's just the problem.
The reason I'm struggling is the the Peterson
acolytes. If no matter what you say, if it's
even remotely critical, they will say you're not
understanding him because you're not smart enough,
so you're misstating what he stands for. He's not
exactly been a fan of any kind of public health
measures being required. Maybe I'll just leave
it at that. He sort of like in that. In that
contingent, he reappeared on the Joe Rogan program
and has become almost a parody of himself. I mean,
I'm just going to look at some clips here and
again, I know I'm stepping in. I'm stepping
on a wasps nest here because everybody's going
to write in who loves this guy and say, David,
you are so ignorant that you don't have the
capacity to understand what he's saying. What he's
saying does make sense, but I encourage you to
prove that to me. Tell me that what he says here
makes any sense other than being the exact type
of nothing means anything post-modern nonsense
that he claims to be against. Take a look at this
Speaker 3: part to sort out the climate change.
One is a weird one, so that won't. That's
because there's no such thing as climate,
right? Climate and everything are the same
word. And that's what bothers me about the
climate change types. It's like, this is the
Speaker 1: types people who are like,
Oh, here's the science.
Speaker 3: Those types bother him,
something that bothers me about it. Technically,
it's like a climate is about everything. OK.
But your models aren't based on everything.
Your models are based on a set number of
variables. Yeah, that means you've reduced the
variables, which are everything to that set. Well,
how did you decide which set of variables to
include in the equation if it's about everything?
And that's not just a criticism, that's like if
it's about everything, your models aren't right
because your models do not and cannot
model everything. What do you mean?
Speaker 1: Now what's crazy about this is
when people say climate is about everything.
I mean, listen. Correct me if I'm wrong.
But when we say climate is about everything,
what I think of is there's these meta issues in
in society, right? And those meta issues are,
you know, our economic system access to health
care, media and climate. And what I mean by
that is if you care about abortion or you care
about net neutrality or you care about whatever.
If you are unable to even sustain yourself
economically, it's hard to be an activist because
you're like, Where's my next meal going to come
from? If you don't have access to health care,
it's hard to be an activist for what matters to
you because you're sick and you don't have care.
And climate is in that meta issue category
in that if we have systemic climate change
that damages the planet and creates death from
pollution and all these, you know, flooding, etc.,
it's hard to be an activist for abortion when
you're being forced to relocate because of rising
sea level. So that's a completely reasonable
way to say climates about everything. But
what Jordan Peterson is saying is nonsense,
and people will say, Scroll down right now on
YouTube. David, you are. You're you're not
understanding the brilliance of this man.
All of these claims are feasible any time. It
sounds like he makes no sense. You can say you
just don't understand what he's saying. It makes
perfect sense. Here is another clip where they
talk about I guess this is about race and how
like when you say someone is white, their skin is
not literally white. And when you say someone is
black, their skin is not literally black. This is
us. I remember this conversation in fifth grade.
In fifth grade, we would say, I'm not really. I
remember a conversation with the teacher. I'm not
really white. My skin is like 10 and two black
kids in the class would say, I'm not really black.
My skin is brown. And we were we were told that
we're not literally guys. This is two grown men
Speaker 3: doing this, depending on who you ask.
Either you're a voice of reason and rationality
and and, you know, personal responsibility, or
you're a voice of intolerance
and bigotry and anger and hateful
sexual oppression. What it might call prejudice.
Dyson call you and meaning three white men.
Yeah, and and a mean angry white man. Hilarious.
Yeah, yeah. You're not mean at all. That's what's
dumb about that statement. It's you're not
mean at all. It's I am white. Actually,
that's a lie, too. I'm kind of tan. And
he was actually not. He was sort of my
because I'm I'm darker than you. Yeah, that's
ridiculous. Yeah. But neither of us are white.
Well, I'm Italian. And he was brown,
not black. Well, isn't that weird? Yeah,
it's really weird. Black and white thing is so
strange because the shades are shown and brown.
There's such a spectrum of shades of pink.
Speaker 1: I had this conversation when I
was 10 with our teacher. I remember
every people saying to the teacher,
Can you explain why we're called white? And
there we figured this out in fifth grade guys.
Speaker 3: But unless you're
talking to someone who is
like 100 percent African from the darkest place
where they're not wearing any clothes all day
and they've developed all that melanin
to protect themselves from the Sun,
you know, even the term black is weird.
Speaker 1: You're not really black
unless you aren't wearing clothes all day. This is
crazy. Guys, is this there are people who worship
this here. Decode this one. And there's
people saying, This is brilliant. Here's
Peterson talking about music theory. And I mean,
you just you have to say it seems like a parody.
Speaker 3: So let's think about what music is.
Yes. First of all, it's it's a pattern. Mm hmm. So
non pattern music is noise. It's a pattern. But
then it isn't one pattern. It's multiple patterns
layered on top of one another. Mm hmm. In a
harmonious manner and in a manner that indicates,
in some sense, communication between all the
pattern layers because they have to go together.
And so what's the world? Well, the world is
made of objects. It's like, No, it's not. It's
made of patterns. So music is just like the
world because the world is made of patterns.
And then music has layered patterns that are
all moving together in a harmonious manner.
Speaker 1: The thing that is frustrating to
me about this is that I'm not saying Jordan
Peterson's a dumb guy, but there's this thing that
happens where it's very common that with lots of
public intellectuals, the way in which they speak
is not particularly accessible to lots of people.
And it starts to be sort of like, Well, I believe
that they're really brilliant. So therefore,
the fact that I don't really get this is probably
my deficit, and I'm sure that everything they're
saying is great. This is an example of where,
like some of the stuff he's saying is kind
of uncontroversial, but it's all being tied
together in what truly is a nonsense word salad.
And it doesn't mean that there's nothing here of
substance, but this is not exactly, you know, the.
The reaction that this clip is getting as
if this is some incredible, brilliant thing,
it's it's really not, and it has to be OK for
us to say that these are very strange rantings.
Speaker 3: And so what do you do when you
hear that, especially if it's got a beat?
Well, then you move your body and you want to
write the music calls to you to move your body.
So now you're moving your body in sync with the
patterned layers of the world. That's meaning. And
then there's more to so that's so cool is music
is an analog of the structure of existence itself,
and it calls to you to take part in
that. So maybe you dance by yourself,
or maybe even better, you dance with someone else.
And so then you both bring your bodies into man.
Speaker 1: I mean, I just I just don't
hear. Here's one about protected classes.
Speaker 3: I think people are going.
Speaker 1: This is part of the culture
war stuff where now you can't joke anymore
Speaker 3: comedy for a different thing today
because they're going after comedy for a literal,
literal representation of what the words mean if
you put them in print. And that's nonsense.
Yeah, but that's not what a comedian. Yeah,
well, they're doing that. They're doing that
because there are some things they believe
that can't be made fun of. Yeah, but the really
what they're doing is just looking for targets.
They're playing a game. The game, the
rules of the game have been established.
Comedy violates the rules of the game. Yeah. What
are the rules when you take those things? Well,
there's a lot of things you can't joke about. You
can't show sacred things. Yeah, there's there's
protected classes now. We all know what they are.
We don't want to bring them up. You know, whether
it's trans people, gay people or people of color.
Speaker 1: And again, this is like the perfect way
to make it seem like, Oh, you know, liberals
just don't want anybody, have fun. You can't
have fun anymore. It's just that they don't.
They don't want any fun. Of course, the real the
truth about comedy and joking about things that
that are sometimes seen as sacred. The truth is
context and intent matters when we make jokes
about Jews or blacks or gays or whatever. And of
course, you can find people who would say you can
never make any joke ever at the expense of these
10 groups. That's a very small portion of people
and leftists like me and others understand context
and understand considering intent, and these can
be blurry areas. But to make it seem as though
it's just come, you can't do comedy anymore. It's
just not allowed if you have these. It's just not
true. All right. Here's the last one. And here's
Jordan Peterson explaining the book The Bible
verses the idea of the Bible. I know, I know.
Speaker 3: So I just walked through the Museum
of the Bible in Washington. That was very cool.
It's very cool music. So that structure. That's
what the book is, what I figured out. I
mean, I just figured this out this week.
So it was a cool. It was a cool thing to walk
through because it's it's chronological. They
have one floor, which is the history of the
Bible. OK? It's not exactly that. It's really
what it is is the history of the book are now
in many ways. The first book was the Bible.
I mean, literally because,
Speaker 1: OK, so wait a second.
The floor is about the history of the Bible,
but it's not about the history of the Bible,
it's about the history of the book.
And the first book was the Bible, OK?
Speaker 3: At one point, there was only one
book, right. As far as our Western culture
is concerned, there is a one book.
Speaker 1: And now are we saying
literally one copy or there was one tome
Speaker 3: while literally there was only
one book and that book was the Bible, and
then before it was the Bible, it was a,
you know, it was scrolls and it was
Speaker 1: weight. So the book that
was the Bible existed before it was a book
or it was existed before it was the Bible
Speaker 3: writings on papyrus. And but it was we
were starting to aggregate written texts together,
and it went through all sorts of technological
transformations and then it became books that
everybody could buy the book everybody could
buy in. The first one of those was the Bible.
Speaker 1: And so how many books are there now?
Speaker 3: We became all sorts of books
that everybody could buy. But all those
books, in some sense, emerged out of that
underlying book and that book itself.
The Bible isn't a book. It's a library.
Speaker 1: It's not a book at all. Guys.
Oh, OK. Bring it on, guys. Come tell me.
I don't understand the genius of that. Come
to tell. I'm ready for it. I'm ready for it.